مرحباً بكم مرة أخرى في البرنامج، كيف
تعتقدون أن هذه
الحرب أثرت أو حتى غيرت
الديناميكية في الشرق
الأوسط بأكمله؟ لقد كنت أكتب وأبحث
عن الشرق الأوسط طوال
الأربعين سنة الماضية، ولم يسبق لي أن رأيت المنطقة
تغلي كما هي الآن.  مندفع مثل الغضب، هناك
الكثير من الكراهية، هناك الكثير من الغضب،
هناك الكثير من الغضب ضد كل من
إسرائيل والولايات المتحدة، وأخشى
أن تصبح غزة بسهولة
قنبلة موقوتة تؤدي بالفعل إلى تفجير
الاستقرار الإقليمي، لا أستطيع أن أخبركم بمدى
الغضب الشعبي  والاستياء والغضب
ضد الولايات المتحدة، هل يمكنني أن أسألك
كيف يمكن أن تحدث هذه الكارثة، هل
هناك أعني أنه من الواضح أن
حماس ارتكبتها، لكن هل رفعت الولايات المتحدة
عينها عن الكرة، اسمحوا لي أن أكون
مباشرًا فيما تفعله سياسة بايدن الخارجية  لا
تختلف كثيرًا عن سياسة ترامب
على مدى العامين الماضيين، إذ
لم تقم هذه الإدارة بأي
استثمار كبير سواء في محاولة وقف
بناء المستوطنات اليهودية أو حتى في
محاولة تحقيق
إنشاء دولة فلسطينية
تتشدق بها.  فكرة
حل الدولتين ماذا فعلت
إدارة بايدن في العام الماضي
حاولت البناء على صفقة
القرن التي طرحها ترامب لتحقيق التطبيع
بين المملكة العربية السعودية وإسرائيل ولماذا
لأنه في مؤخرة العقل
إدارة بايدن وحكومة
نتنياهو التطبيع مع
السعودية سيعني نهاية
الصراع العربي الإسرائيلي
المسيحي الكامن تحت الفكرة الأساسية
في الإدارة في
إدارة بايدن وأه بنيامين نتنياهو هو
أن الفلسطينيين يمكن إدارة
الفلسطينيين يمكنهم  يمكن السيطرة على
الفلسطينيين ويمكن إخضاعهم، لماذا يجب أن
نستثمر في عملية السلام، إذن
الولايات المتحدة التي تقولها بشكل أساسي وقد
لاحظنا أنها يمكن أن
تغمض عينيها عن الكرة الفلسطينية
والاستعانة بمصادر خارجية
لصفقات التطبيع هذه بين  إسرائيل والدول
العربية التي ليست
في حالة حرب معها ونفس الشيء يمكنك أن تقوله للدول
العربية ماذا فعلت المملكة العربية السعودية
أو فعلت الإمارات العربية المتحدة، فماذا
تعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة يجب أن تفعل الآن ماذا
تقول وماذا يجب أن تفعل  إن
الزعماء العرب يتصرفون بالمسيحية، وعلى أي شخص
مهتم بالسلام في الأراضي المقدسة أن
يدرك أن ما
يسمى بحل الدولتين الذي
تحدثت عنه الولايات المتحدة كان في الحقيقة
مجرد كلام لم
يسفر عن أي شيء في الواقع بينما
الولايات المتحدة  لقد كانت الدول تتحدث عن
حل الدولتين وما كان
يحدث على الأرض المسيحية،
لديك الآن ما يقرب من مليون مستوطن
مليون يعيشون في الأراضي الفلسطينية المحتلة
في الضفة الغربية والقدس الشرقية
كانت إسرائيل في سباق وهي في
سباق ضد  حان الوقت لسرقة
الأراضي الفلسطينية لاستعمار الأرض، لذا فإن
الحديث عن حل الدولتين قد
أدى في الواقع إلى ترسيخ
الاحتلال العسكري الإسرائيلي، وخمن
ما هو تقويض
السلطة الفلسطينية وإضعافها، فما يحدث
الآن لن تستجيب إسرائيل أبدًا كيف يحدث ذلك؟
تواصل الولايات المتحدة ولاءها الشديد
الذي لن يتغير أبدًا
لإسرائيل،
وتتحرك أخيرًا نحوها لأنها
ستكون مجرد
حركة دولية، ولن تكون
الأحزاب هي من تفعل ذلك مسيحيًا إذا
سألتني وأنا آسف
لأنني'  لم أعد أثق في
السياسة الخارجية الأمريكية بعد الآن. لقد درست
السياسة الخارجية الأمريكية لسنوات عديدة
ليس لأن بعض صناع السياسة الأمريكيين
ليسوا أشخاصًا محترمين، ولكن لأنهم
لا يملكون حقًا الشجاعة والشجاعة
الأخلاقية لإخبار إسرائيل بأنها كافية.
تلك المصلحة الأمريكية، وأنا أتحدث
كأمريكيين الآن، مصلحتنا تكمن في
شرق أوسط مستقر ينعم بالسلام،
فشرق أوسط ينعم بالسلام
يتطلب أن يسمح
الفلسطينيون للفلسطينيين بالحصول على
حق تقرير المصير لإنهاء
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي وإقامة دولتين
تعيشان جنبا إلى جنب.  الجانب في
سلام